father armand sent you
thank you very much
uh
[Music]
hello
it's been far too long dear prince
hmm is this your army
you couldn't possibly be thinking of
using this rabble against lord sherrod
would you
the throne belongs to its rightful owner
and my spies tell me you haven't even
been able to activate vanquisher
it's time to yield the sword disband
this gang of criminals and plead for
mercy
and we may let you live
if sherrod really wants this so badly
he's welcome to come fetch it brave but
foolish words young prince
you will regret this boy
[Laughter]
let him go
we don't kill messengers
even rude ones
oh
good
you've arrived safely
vanquisher is an heirloom of the
lutheran dynasty
it's supposed to glow when held by the
rightful heir to the crown
that's how my ancestors
proved their worthiness
which is also why sharon seeks
vanquisher for himself
but it won't even show the faintest
glimmer in my hands
what does that say about me
huh
[Music]
your highness i
i was only
following orders following orders
did you really just say that
innocent villagers are dead
by your hand
do you have no will of your own can you
not see the difference between right and
wrong
you
are no true knight of luterra
you are responsible for these atrocities
and you will face justice for them
i have spoken
take him away
your highness you must not spare his
life yeah your highness you must not
spare his life
yeah
you deserve it
you deserve it
are the rumors true
all the harm done to the villagers is my
fault
[Music]